Hey, DT is watching on Twitch. What are
you going to do? You almost thought you
got me. You almost thought you had me,
but not today. He's just showing fire
for the first time. He's just showing
fire for the first time. He's like
>> Yes. You're really
Are you trying to like make things hot?
Like what the How are you How are you
doing I don't know what I'm looking at
here. Do you think Hutch is aware that
he's nowhere near as intelligent as his
son? Do you think he knows that like
>> Probably not. No, he probably genuinely
thinks he's smarter than his son.
You please just explain the situation.
Okay, so there is a clipping Discord
that I'm a part of, okay? I will ask for
links to stuff. Uh I will suggest clips
to people. I'll retweet other people's
clips. Right? Basically, they're trying
to post like cut up logs with absent any
context as if this is like an evil
doxing server. Destiny wants this to go
and flow into his greater narrative that
I'm running like a cabal that's been
working against him, that hates him, and
wants to undermine everything he's ever
done.
So, but he did this. He said, "Got to
say I'm not terribly surprised to have
found this in the leaked snark Discord
logs. Folks, this is online politics. If
you're invoking dead family members over
this stuff, you're years overdue for
extensive therapy. Delete your accounts
and reevaluate." So, they cut off
whoever the [__] this was. Now, if
someone like that was doing something
like that, I think that there would
probably be a level of value in at least
putting the screen name there. You want
the people that own the server to be
able to go, "No, we saw that and we've
banned them." But, this isn't what I do.
I've never been like this.
Okay, hold on. I got to go find Hutch's
stream. I actually haven't grabbed it
here at all. Give me a second. Give me a
second. Give me a second.
It's not going to scramble. This is the
one. This is the one.
So, here's this. He's got a 5-hour
54-minute vod on YouTube.
8 hours?
Oh my god.
I think uh today a snarker was born,
okay? Welcome to the snark side, Hutch.
Welcome, my friend.
Doesn't it feel liberating to just admit
that you didn't really have political
like goals? You were just a guy who did
internet drama. Doesn't that feel
liberating? Isn't that a liberating
feeling?
Yes, I am a snarker. YES, I DO LOVE
SNARKING. Welcome to the team, Hutch.
Welcome to the team.
You don't get it. He doesn't participate
in these spaces. I've heard this. I've
heard Hutch is not a drama streamer.
He's a political streamer and sometimes
he looks at drama. Occasionally looks at
drama. Occasionally.
Like him trying to walk through the film
on stuff and just not understanding what
like anything that's going on would be
very funny.
Does he have some kind of an automated
website? I'm assuming that's what this
is where you automate to like
monitor people's streams or is this just
monitoring everyone's streams? I don't
even know what I'm looking at here. He's
like looking so desperately
to discern that it's actually shocking.
Oh my god, a website exists on the
internet where you can search me?
Oh my god. Dude, he's like the guy from
Gremlins. What voice? What kind of voice
is he doing there? What is that voice?
It's a voice. It's a voice.
What What you
A website exists on the internet where
you can search me? I'm hamming it up
now, okay?
That's fair, Top Bronson, that he
wouldn't even moderate his chat going
after Pisco. Of course, he's not going
to moderate his chat going after me. Of
course not. That's fine. That's a level
of onlineness that I never that I never
reached, but I I genuinely
had no idea that this was a thing. Uh
the trip was $5. Damn, this moment is
telling. It could be
It could just be that they have no legit
human interaction because they didn't
vibe well with others, so the only I
don't know. Listen, I don't want to I I
it's a pretty safe assumption that
the level of activity, the frequency of
activity in this Discord channel
very
I [laughter] love that character.
I [__]
>> That is a little bit like the voice.
That That was a discerning chatter who
donated that. That is very similar to
the voice, actually. Love that movie.
>> good stuff.
Matt Reeves is such a
legend. He could have Oh god, he's going
to go way off He's going to go way off
on a tangent here. thinking about that
movie.
Hello.
It's gone.
What's up?
Yeah, it's uh Watching some Hutch.
Yeah, I was just checking out Hutch.
Apparently watched me for like 8 hours
today, 7 hours or something.
>> [laughter]
>> the involvement in the community that
you feel as a part of this like snarky
Maybe that's filling a hole that you
have, I don't know. My god.
Some kind of an automated website? I'm
assuming that's what this is? Where you
automate the like
monitor people's streams? Or is this
just monitoring everyone's streams? I
don't even know what I'm looking at
here. Search within YouTube subtitles,
captions, and and transcripts. It's just
like K Mon bro. This is
He's just flying off for the first time.
He's like Yes. You're really You're
trying to You're really trying to like
make things hot? Like what the
How you How you doing How you doing
looking at here? It's like bright and
hot at the same time? How is How?
>> Search It's just a broad search. It
searches like the whole internet.
It's just It doesn't even like
It basically like is You're not
downloading anything to your computer.
And for Hutch's channel, and as far as
Ogre Boy is concerned, Hutch's channel
has just been indexed for a long time.
Okay.
This is the funny thing. It's like once
all this is explained, you understand
that Hutch's whole thing about being
surveilled 24/7 entirely falls apart the
moment he doesn't understand what Film
Mod is. It's in the
logs.
You guys are actively watching my
content live obsessively. This is not
I just want to point out that for today
I couldn't get a single person to give
me timestamps for this. I have to go and
find myself. Okay, okay.
Can I actually explain to me if if this
is so evil, how the does he think all
the Hasan clips get generated that he
covers? How the does he think the
anti-Hasan machine runs? What does he
think is happening? Does he think it's
Hasan's fans going around posting those
clips? Do you think people just
genuinely enjoy watching Hasan's
content? They catch these moments and
they go and make a bunch. No, there are
legions upon legions of obsessed
liberal right-wing Discord
that sit around staring at Hasan all day
and hate this guy cuz he limits and
that's what that's all they do all day
and they cry about it. They get deranged
about it and then they go and post about
it. They post about who is a terrorist.
They post about who kids. Who is
listening to this?
>> to know a funny thing? Do you want to
know a funny thing? Is actually the
first Film Mod equivalent that I became
aware of was this one right here.
knowyourdestiny.dev.
This was for Destiny. Do you want to
know who they quickly expanded to as a
secondary source for YouTube
transcripts?
>> Hasan.
Hasan [__] So, like we're literally
just following in footsteps here, okay?
We're trying to catch up to people
who've already built this exact into No,
that's that's like operated with for a
long period of time. That that's the the
DGG have like a million things like
this. They have like a bunch of
different web projects and all this that
they've set up over the years that have
been tracking different people and
all this [__] They've always done that.
It's like that this is these are your
people, bro. It's your guys. Hutch
thinks like Willy Mac gets me to look
like he's above 60 IQ with no effort.
No, bro. It took a lot of effort from a
lot of people, okay? It took a
Herculean It was It was a Herculean
task.
>> a village. Takes a village, as they say.
Not just about transcripts. He knows
this. I don't know why he's doing this.
That was specifically Tony that was
doing that, who was apparently working
on a video for like months that I don't
know if it ever came out, but
But then they would have these like
watch parties for Livin' Learn, and
you know, like they weren't watch Yeah,
we're fans of Livin' Learn.
We're all We're all fans of Livin'
Learn. What?
What's wrong with that? watching my
stuff as religiously as they were
watching other creators, but there would
be uh most days, I want to say, there
would be like days that I was live, you
know, you would see like is anybody
watching Hutch live right now? He's
being so regarded on this thing. Did it
or
Like stuff like that. And then, you
know, like
and then there were
Yeah, and
they destroyed like every Discord in
this whole space. Like Like every
Discord in this whole space would have
people doing this. People would be I
think I did this in my Discord today. I
asked if people were watching I might
have asked if they were watching Hutch
live cuz I heard he was watching me.
Like every Everybody says this in every
Discord ever. Hey, what are you guys
doing? Anyone watching this? They're
content creator Discords. They're
content-centric Discords. Of course,
people are going to ask these questions.
Or more examples of like targeted stuff
where they're like boosting tweets that
are or brigading posts and stuff like
that. There was like plenty of plenty of
that as well. On the anti-Starker side,
this
[__]
this fantastic [__] has
come into this video. He's trying to
tell you that these people are stalking
me. They're finding videos from like 10
years ago. Oh my god. And he is unaware
that you could just search the
transcripts.
He can't even disagree with that. He
literally just said you were unaware of
that. Is a totally unreliable person. He
is totally out of his depth trying to
talk about this. And he's basically
lying to slander other people to create
a permission structure to docs them. So,
thank you, Hutch. He doesn't understand
what he's participating in at all.
No, he's just a bot. Um people have been
posting like what Destiny said is my
location in in the chat repeatedly. And
he gets to do this face.
He gets to do this face after I suggest
that.
Stupid Uh
Oh, we're on Twitch. We're on Twitch.
We're on Twitch. Hey, Twitch. Hey,
Twitch. Hey, DGG is watching on Twitch
waiting to do You almost thought you got
me. You almost thought you had me, but
not today. Not today, okay? What? What?
He just took a gigantic leap there. What
the
That's very funny.
Hutch just I don't know if he Does he
think to tell his like his mods? I don't
know. Maybe he just doesn't think of it.
I actually watch my chat. So, for me,
like I I know if I see somebody spamming
like info like that in my chat, I just I
get rid of them really quick. I've
always got an eye on it. I don't know
what Hutch's excuse is here, but What
did he just say? I just [__] For
coming into this whole situation Denims,
actually, uh I thought had some issues
with moderating a chat that Hutch was
very upset about.
Oh, yeah.
Well, you know, that's that's Denims.
That is Denims, okay?
>> Yeah, that's them, and this is us. She's
like anti-Semitic, I heard. So,
realistically, she needs to be a better
person. So, Hutch is trying to create
the standard for being totally insane,
totally unhinged, totally crazy.
And who built this custom themselves
before anybody else on the internet had
an open channel that they could just add
whatever they wanted to?
Who did that? UH
OH, IT WAS DGG. WAIT, REALLY? YES, I'm
Listen, I say first is the first one I
was aware of, and there was not a broad
generic search before that, okay? Uh
Rintharp with $5, damn you didn't know
about a website. This clearly
invalidates everything, case closed. For
the record, I think some parts of DGG
can be
way too online and obsessive
in ways that I
don't think is healthy.
But will also monetize and take
advantage of as much as humanly
possible, including watching 7 hours of
your vod today. Which by the way, I just
make it clear, I've no problem with. I
love that hard that Hutch is coming over
to the snark side, okay? That he's seen
the the snark side of things. I love
that for him. Is that if he doesn't
think this is like uniquely bad, then
what what is even the point of this
coverage? Why is he spending 6 hours a
day talking about this?
Well, it's obviously more harmful than
Trump or anything else that's going on
in American politics right now, idiot.
Hey, live your life, do what makes you
happy, but
I don't know if he's looking for some
kind of a contradiction. I think this
kind of behavior
obsessive behavior is just generally,
you know, like
probably not fulfilling to people on a
spiritual level. I'm not joking, this is
something I This is how you he gives
away that he can't possibly win, right?
Cuz he's giving away that it's not
fulfilling to him on a spiritual level.
And he assumes that that is what's is
true for everybody else, right? That's
like, "Oh, buddy, you got no idea.
You're
You're somewhere you don't want to be,
and I'm in like my happy place. I'm in
I'm in like the zone. I'm having a great
time every day. I wake up, I have a
great I'm very confident on. And it
isolates the clips, too.
Uh you know what's funny is I was just
thinking last night, like, you know
what? I wonder how he's doing.
This is It's so funny that this is the
example that he brings up. Is me calling
attention to the fact that we've done
like an ogre boy ban
ban in the in the chat. I wonder what
he's up to.
And so, I'm just saying for everybody
here, okay?
What is the website? It's filmot. Film
ot. filmot.com.
Subscribe to the Patreon like I have.
I subscribed to the Patreon cuz I use it
a decent amount, right?
If I want to go find stuff for anything.
And if you search on filmot it pulls up
a captcha unless you sign up for the
Patreon, so.
Uh yeah, it searches the transcripts and
uses timestamps to clip from the vod,
right? Yeah, exactly.
Which is very funny. I The funny thing
is is I built this myself like three
summers ago.
YouTube transcript search It piped it
into a like an elastic search index,
essentially. It was It was It wasn't
elastic search. It was a Lucene
compliant search index. Basically, just
something you use to search text. Don't
worry about it if you don't know. And it
would timestamp all the logs. And so you
would search through and I've just
listen, I've never been this like I
think I'm pretty engaged
in online discourse. I think I'm pretty
engaged specifically like in online
political discourse. I've just never
been this engaged. I'm not I'm not
necessarily judging. It's like, "Okay,
if that's your passion, but
I've never been that
I I've never been I've never felt a
motivation to run that kind of like
automated system of like focusing on
specific creators in this kind of way.
So, he's saying he's saying he's not
that engaged, right? It's like
Okay.
You clearly care about it, right? You
are You He's saying he's engaged. He's
saying he cares about it. He's saying
he's not that engaged. I understand not
wanting to spend all of your time doing
this. That's kind of the point of
automating it is that you can do more
with less time.
That's that's the point of having
archivers, having clippers, having
people praying your dockets, having
automated systems for doing that is is
to be able to do more with less time,
have more of an impact, be more
effective with less time. So, why would
you not do that? If you're even remotely
engaged, why would you not do that?
I'm just trying to think in my head
you think Hutch just doesn't understand
how like journalism works or No. No, he
did not just
Just be normal.
Just be normal. Who's got the s-
It's just normal. It's so normal to just
not care about your job.
>> it's like so
cuz it's like
all the sh- he does, all the songs he
covers requires a bunch of people not
being normal. He's not normal when he
covers Hasan. It just To to act like Oh,
you have to stop doing this cuz this
this isn't normal. It's like you just
You just say you don't like hearing it.
Just say you don't want us to exist
online. Just say you don't want us to be
effective. Just say that cuz that's what
you mean. That's what you mean. You're
mad there's a bunch of people who hate
you and they're motivated to point out
the ways in which you're lying to people
or you're really stupid or you're
self-interested and you don't like that.
You don't like they do that because you
don't want what happened to Hasan to
happen to you. It's going to, buddy.
It's going to.
Do you think Hutch is aware that he's
nowhere near as intelligent as Hasan? Do
you think he knows that like
>> Holy no. No, he probably genuinely
thinks he's smarter than Hasan.
Yeah, that's unfortunate.
And by the way, I don't think either of
us think Hasan's like a world beater in
terms of IQ. I just It's just Hutch.
It's just Hutch. Who's got the um the
Bastiat Tangia? Just be normal. Don't do
this obsessive
>> that mean Hutch will be that relevant.
That's It's not quite what I meant by
you know the Hasan you know his gravity.
I just mean he's going to get the same
sort of criticism and that's how it
works.
And also obviously he will not have a
massive
you know
Hutch is never going to be on a on a
million thumbnails, you know, being like
He's He's done now. He's 1,000% good. No
one's ever going to give that much of a
[__] about Hutch.
No third worlders are ever going to be
able to make a like incredible living
off of Hutch. It's never going to
happen, man. Facts. And then be like, uh
have you ever heard of journalism? He
did There's no way he just said that.
I mean, he was really like racking his
brain.
How do I react to that? Oh, let's frame
it as journalism.
It's no way he just said that. Or
or like video content creation works,
anything.
He's literally like, "Oh, this guy's
like trying to verify claims he made."
And He's not trying to verify claims I
made. He's constantly searching for his
name on the internet. That's like
Why?
Because well, actually it's claim you
made. I don't know what I meant there.
It sounded like I meant Ogerboy, but
it's a claim Hutch made. Hutch said, "I
have an Ogerboy policy. I haven't
mentioned Ogerboy since back here." And
Ogerboy goes, "Oh, really?" And then he
pulls up Phil Mott and he searches
Ogerboy. Like he just wants to in real
time verify the claim.
Obviously.
different. That's not the same thing as
journalism. That's just
I That's a level of of self-indulgence
that You see how he can't let it play
for very long? Like he he just paused it
there. I said journalism or video
content creation, any of this stuff
where you like have to do research,
verify your claims. Like obviously
somebody's going to make this process
more efficient.
But he's basically saying, "Oh, you said
you're a journalist. Oh my god, you
think you're like a journalist?" No.
Nobody's arguing that, Hutch. Most
creators don't even do.
Well, established creators. And he's not
using chat GPT.
What a sad, strange little man.
What?
stuff that he's saying in a private
Discord. And then but but this level of
sad, like this level of [__]
pathetic.
We're just we have completely fallen off
the cliff.
Phil Mott. Phil Mott is totally
pathetic, guys. If you try to search for
mentions of a word, of a concept, does
Hutch not realize how powerful This is
what we call kind of a combination No,
no, no. Hold on.
Maybe he did it. He would have to
apologize to Ogerboy before anything
else here, right? He's implying Ogre Boy
using this tool, having this tool is
totally pathetic. Ogre Boy is a total
loser for this.
And now he's going to try to get out of
apologizing for that and saying he was
wrong. No, you you made a bunch of reads
about Ogre Boy not knowing what this
was. You should apologize for that,
obviously.
of a straw man and a motte and bailey.
Little bit of both in there. Okay.
That's specifically what I'm calling
pathetic. Is like Filmon or do you think
it's like part of like a larger context?
Do you think this is just one one
element of Ogre Boy's very apparent
obsession with me?
what this tool is for making his
arguments when he's talking about other
content creators? Does he not realize
where all of this [__] that people found
on Hasan? He's not doing that though.
He's not like active in debates. He's
just looking he's just he just logs into
the internet every day, I guess, and
just pulls up Here's here's the thing.
If you are a
Oh, how would I If you're like a
creator, and I mean that like a sort of
spiritual sense. If you're like a
creator, if you're like a builder, if
you If you're looking to be
somebody who iterates and and makes
things better in the world, you should
see this tool and go, "Holy I didn't
even know this was possible." Like a a
person that I would want to interact
with or collab with would look at this
tool and go, "Holy This is possible?
Well, that's awesome. Oh, I need that.
Oh, how do you How do you use this?"
Right? They wouldn't go, "Oh, you're so
creepy and weird for wanting to know
about this." Like this inherent disgust
at new knowledge is very concerning for
me.
I think your reaction to this should
just objectively be, "Oh my god, you can
search all of YouTube? What? Like I can
search for Hutch specifically? I can
search for like Hasan across all of
YouTube? What? What?" Filmon searches
for Ogre Boy looking for like any crumb
of online attention.
comes from? Do you not realize that when
people want to make a point about Hasan
with regards to Marxism or communism?
I'm almost positive when Ogre Boy is
looking this up, by the way, it's to
verify claim that Hutch made about how
he stopped talking about Ogre Boy months
ago. And Ogre Boy looks it up and goes,
"Oh, look at the mentions of OgreBoy
here." Or what's the other one?
Re-education.
Right? They use this website. All of
your people who get you links would use
a website just like this.
All of my people who give me links
Listen, sometimes you guys give me some
stuff to point out to, but I I
personally pick
probably like 99% of the stuff that I I
don't maybe he operates this way where
he's got people like feeding him clips.
I don't do that.
I mean, I do, but that's cuz I want to
have like all the best
I Yeah, I do.
But why is Hutch pretending he doesn't?
Is Hutch saying that his obsession with
Hasan was just all him? Nobody sent him
links for that?
I just don't think that's true. Or at
least I hoped it wasn't true.
But hey, maybe.
Maybe maybe. I'm a normal person. I
don't play this game that you play.
I I assume this is projection. I assume
people feed you clips and these kinds of
things. Okay, yes he does. He does play
this game. What does he mean?
Is the Hasan thing here? We're all
playing the same game, bro. We're all
playing the same game. How dare It
really does come down to just How dare
you be effective? How dare you be better
at this than me? How dare you? You're
like weird cuz you're you're You're like
making good points and you're like
>> few of you, but but you seem so loud.
It's so annoying. It's so annoying.
Why does it hit so hard even though
there's so few of you? That's that
[__] annoys me so much.
Okay?
Is that okay? fantastic tool. If you
ever wanted to debate with somebody who
disagrees with you, like a content
creator, you could go and find their
positions that they've held and see if
they're like wobbly on this, see where
they're wobbly on this, see how they
argue it. It would be fantastic for you.
It's like an
Honestly, moving forward, I might use
it. Wasn't aware of this. It would have
been helpful in a few debates.
I thought you wanted to disengage. I
thought you just wanted to disengage.
It turns out this is not loser behavior.
It turns out Oh my god.
>> this is pretty useful. Turns out
actually it's kind of awesome.
This is good for you.
>> He's been just as much mentioning me as
anything.
No.
I should be Negative.
>> The last thing on his mind. What is that
based on, Hutch? Hutch, what is that
based on? I've been
I could ask Claude. Hang on, let me ask
Claude. Estimate how much time in
[clears throat]
raw total hours that Ogre Boy spent.
He's going to ask Oh, did he upload all
the logs into Claude or something?
Watching my streams or talking about
me in this channel. Dude, there's no way
There's no way that's a context clue.
>> What is he
Does he have it
Yeah, there's no way
if he's asking like AI or giving it no
context clues whatsoever, that's That
would be shocking.
>> How many total hours? It's thinking.
It's thinking.
Har Star says 69 hours. You think Claude
can do that? LOL.
>> [laughter]
>> Dude, I
>> We got 80 hours, 67, 300, 1,000. That is
ambitious. I don't know if I would have
gotten that high, but maybe honestly
maybe. I'll let it hit. I've got pause.
>> The memer seems to have got it right.
Har Star, you nailed it, buddy. This
says 69 hours. He wasn't even the most
Actually wait, hold on. Is this 74
hours? Hang on, we got to refine this a
little bit. Hang on.
Ap- Apparently there were there were
other users that like doubled his hours.
Okay, this is something set up with the
context for the logs. I got it. Oh man,
this is so powerful.
There's no way
Dude, imagine how obsessed you'd have to
be to set up like a Chat GPT context
that you could share around or for Hutch
to set it up with
Where he puts all of these logs into it.
Or somebody else sets it up and he's
given like access to it.
Why does he take the fruits of labor of
so many obsessed people
and use them directly and then mock
others who do the same?